In the Indian Ocean
another mom said time her journey
to perfection.
On a tiny speck of land
Monsoon rains trigger
a miracle of nature.
She may not look that impressive,
but this little Christmas Island
red crab around the size of your hand
is on a mission to become
a mom.
Crabs evolved in the sea.
But she's completely adapted to a life
on land,
almost.
Her babies will only develop in saltwater.
But to get there, a five mile
trek from her home in the forest,
all the way down
to the beach.
It's a long way on four inch legs,
especially walking sideways.
At least she's got company.
70 million moms and dads
to be called back to the ocean once a year
to breed.
This big
little journey can take two weeks.
And on the way,
there will be casualties.
Ten times her size, the largest land
crab on earth.
Robber crab.
Armed with crustacean crushing pincers.
The red crabs
eyesight is so bad that it's easy
to run into trouble,
and harder to get out
alive.
Unless luck is on your side.
But there are bigger dangers
still to face.
She's got time this,
just right.
Fortunately, on lots of roads here today,
the crabs get the right of way.
A million strong march
all arrive
right on schedule at the beach.